our shoutout tonight goes to a veteran
reporter in Louisville Kentucky who's
been a journalist there for some four
decades but few of the stories have had
the impact of a powerful series he just
produced on what could only be called
the crime of driving while black until
the Louisville courier-journal began to
investigate this was standard procedure
for the city's police violent crime unit
black motorist pulled over on traffic
stops and then ordered out of their cars
often put in handcuffs and then their
vehicles searched for drugs or weapons
courier-journal reporter Andrew Wolfson
documented the disturbing pattern we had
heard about this anecdotally but I
wanted to see if we could prove it we
found that the blacks we're stopped
we had a proportion with whites even
though somewhat unexpectedly whites were
more likely to be found with guns and
other contraband and Wilson backed up
his research by obtaining police body
cameras to show just how it happened 18
year old Tian lei had no criminal
records and had just graduated from high
school where he was the homecoming king
when he was pulled over driving his
mother's car he was told he'd made a
turn that was too wide leave was pulled
out of his car mama they taking me out
the vehicle shouting to his mother on
his cell phone connection about what was
going on
demanding to know from the police why he
was being treated this way why are you
checking me I didn't say you did
anything so you know out the car quit
with the attitude he's not giving you an
attitude and I'm not giving you an
attitude
we deal with violent crime all day every
day we're gonna stop 30 more people
after you we're here for you man there's
a shooting every day it's crazy sad
there was one officer in particular who
kept asking the young man why he has
such a bad attitude towards police as
they were standing him up in the hot Sun
on an August day handcuffed behind his
back as the public drove by yeah so it
was it was pretty outrageous in the case
of t-yong lead police did not find any
drugs or weapons or anything other than
an angry mother who came to the scene to
help her son ma'am stay over there
please if you approach my traffic stop I
will take luckily enough for you ma'am
luckily enough for you everything was
captured on body camera okay the police
chief said it was the only way to get
guns off the street and reduce the
city's rapidly escalating murder rate
and you talked to police experts who
said this is may be lawful but not good
policing right one part of it they said
was clearly unlawful and that was
frisking this young man without probable
cause without any evidence that he was
armed and dangerous
in another case documented by Wolfson
and the courier-journal Jamal Johnson an
auto worker with no criminal record was
pulled over for an issue with a turn
signal step back I think it was what was
unusual about his cases if I remember it
correctly was it he was so suspicious of
police that he had his own camera a
video camera mounted in his in his car
so he captured his own stop the
courier-journal stories hit a nerve in
the
picked up by local television this is
the traffic stop that sparked outrage in
Louisville officers question the team
and asked to search his car now the
Louisville police chief has issued new
traffic stop rules to restrict ten
cuffing and searches these policies aim
to strike a balance between the concerns
of the community and the need for us to
conduct traffic stops for both safety
and investigative reasons I guess I was
most I was happy that it prompted two
changes the policy on to two separate
fronts it's rare to get results
especially that quickly so that was
pleasing Andy Wilson may be an old pro
but he's still very much at the top of
his game that's our program for tonight
thanks for joining us we'll see you back
here in next week